she's the original fly girl and has been
holding it down ever since her debut
album all hail the queen
she went on to win grammys emmys golden
globes and she was nominated for an
oscar for her role as mama in chicago
give it up for queen latifah y'all
yes bravo bravo um we need to get you an
egot
at this point you're missing one i gotta
get my egot on
yeah i mean i mean egt is still great so
i'm not frowning at that um
so did you hear the twins reaction to
your song what did you think
that's so cute oh my goodness
oh man that's cool i think that's cool i
think that's cool
isn't it funny like a whole different
generation like gets to hear i just love
them listening to songs that i've like
used to roller skate to or like grow up
and like that's their first time it's
crazy if you watch all their series it's
hilarious
because it's these songs you think that
they'd know and then they're like so
shocked by it it's awesome so wait i
actually heard something interesting
you're a country music fan which i love
so what song is like one of your
favorites
uh devil went down georgia what
i love that really sounds like kind of a
rap record if you think about it like it
was like
that was like like a a country
rap record i was like wait a minute you
know this is dope um i heard something
from florida georgia line the other day
i don't know the name of the song
but i was like the pocket of the song
felt very hip-hop
yeah but the song was country yeah you
know what i mean
so i was like i like i like their
combination of it you know and i love
that country music is now
like really i think i think country
music is really
uh really leaning into so many other
genres now i think it's it's pulling
from a little hip-hop
it's pulling from a little r b mate well
it's always like got
like blues under it too yeah so like but
i think
i like it pulling from some of like the
hip hop the track
kind of you know pockets you know you
you're starting to hear some of that in
in the songs that you didn't really hear
before and um
i actually was gonna go to the country
music awards the last one
because i really just i love some of
those i just
love some of those performances and
they're funny to me yeah like
i like watching usually when blake and
luke just like
snap on each other for an hour or two
just crack jokes on each other i'm like
that's funny to me
but uh uh i think um yeah i like i like
carrie underwood and anything you do is
just like come on girl oh you're so nice
you don't have to complement me ever
again you've made my life so i
love that you know me all right so i saw
your starring in a tv reboot of the
equalizer which i love those films so
how is that going
it's going you know we were two days
away from shooting and then the world
shut down yeah and now we are about to
be shooting in less than eight weeks you
know so
it just like turned back on real quick
so now i'm like oh
it's exciting because um
the the tv show i used to watch when i
was a kid
um and then of course we fell in love
with the denzel movies
but now i get to create my own version
of it and i'm a woman
as well so i'm a woman who gets to kick
some behind
um but you know the equalizer is about
justice
it's about making things equal it's
about fighting for
you know people who who can't fight for
themselves with
with this amazing skill set you know so
i get to like you know i get to met some
justice out there and i'm looking
forward to it i get to use the hands i'm
like
[Applause]
oh my gosh you're living my like dream
life
this is awesome and the fact that the
woman affected a woman's dream because i
love the denzel movies i mean i've seen
them so much i literally
i could recite the script so but i love
that a woman's doing it
and i think that it's just a completely
different perspective what a cool way to
like reboot it for tv
um and like you said just a woman like
bringing justice like i just
ain't no woman like a woman pissed off
y'all like so i'm i'm so excited
um hey before you we go though i want
you to tell me you've got a huge event
tomorrow so what's going on
huge event tomorrow um doing
the hashtag act for an impact live
stream event
saturday september 26th it'll be at 7 pm
eastern time it's with the american lung
association
it's a live stream event to raise money
for
uh people who have been impacted by
covert 19
it's particularly black and brown
communities those
underserved communities who've been
really hit
hard they're going to advocate for us
they they
recognize that this is going to be a
problem way back in april so they
started the
the coven 19 action initiative to raise
money
uh to protect people um
they want to give out masks you know so
people can protect themselves
those who don't have them or can't get
them
they prevent it you know obviously and
they want to
make sure they can do research uh make
sure that the
when the vaccines are ready that they go
to those who really need them
you know there are a lot of people that
have been out there on the front lines
and so
the black and brown communities we've
been getting hit particularly hard
um and pretty much because of
financial issues as well you know and
this whole thing is
like a huge light to the disparities
between uh black and white well not just
black and white but
white people and everybody else yeah you
know when it comes to
the healthcare system so um
i think this is so many people
especially a lot of my white friends and
i'm sure yours and everybody has been
like what can we do what can we do what
can we
here's one of the things you can do help
people out you know help people
uh who who really need it um and and and
this
this event that we're having is gonna be
a lot of fun we're gonna have
you know some of my friends like jimmy
fallon jill scott we got
common quest love um
gavin duane kiki palmer we got
performances
fitz and the tantrums are gonna come
perform but people are gonna perform and
tell their their stories
uh about how it's affected their
families and we're also going to have
real doctors on there to explain and
educate
um so that people really understand
what's happening
take the politics out of it and really
just
understand it so that we can all to come
together
and fight this thing yeah i know i agree
agreed i cannot wait to
watch it that's amazing um and i can't
i'm one of those kids that loves to
learn as well so i can't wait to hear
all
the doctors as well um well okay so
speaking of have a good time i love food
um so
there's no segway for this so i'm
bringing this up because
i think this is hilarious did you know
that someone honored you with a sandwich
did you know that there's a sandwich
named after you and it's
awesome what yes and i'm so
jealous i want a sandwich so sammich
restaurant in ashland oregon is serving
the queen leba
the queen leba come on
my assistant jonathan is handing me
a queen leba yes okay y'all it comes
i love you so much justin it comes with
steak jalapeno cream cheese spread and
red onion on sourdough rice
so i'm just saying we should taste it
it's a queen labifa
cause it's just never that's never gonna
not be funny this is the largest
sandwich in the entire world
ava oh damn that's good
yeah is it good yes it's so good
your queen label sandwich is so good
[Laughter]
look i'm about to spray my queen of beef
covered friendly um it is so good
you've got to try it it's so good thank
you so much sammich restaurant ashland
oregon that was amazing
all right so be sure y'all see you like
it don't you it's so good get that
little bit yep
you're so classy i totally talked with
my mouth open i got to take lessons on
class from the queen
it's all about this right here that's me
too yes
it's so good yeah i mean
i know i like some spice i like some
spice hey well thank you so much for
joining us everybody be sure to watch
queen latifah host the act for
impact virtual fundraiser for the
american lung association tomorrow night
it's really important it'll be fun too
you can see it online at facebook.com
long usa